hey this is Pete peppers and this is a
candy crush saga saga level 1 59
walkthrough tutorial this is a level
that gives people trouble and had some
people asking about it in my group so
I'm going to go ahead and play through
complete it and explain some of the
important tips when you first start off
you have these three soda bottles that
are behind the honey in the middle so
the first thing you would do is pop
those reason is because no new bottles
come onto the board until they pop and
then you see there that orange one came
out right away after I pop the last
month so the trick in the first room is
to continue popping the bottles and then
keep bringing them out right here and
you don't want to get the bear by the
street because this is the easiest room
to pop the bottles in so like you see
there I went around I worked around it
and I'm going to do that again I'm going
to move this striped over so that it
won't push the bear up because I want to
keep it in there until I have around 25
moves left and just pop bottles all you
do is you just they come out right there
so you make a match that will move one
down in a bottle pops off and then you
just want to pop it as soon as you can
the fish will go for it so here I can
match these two fish and they'll eat up
some of the honey in front of the thing
but we won't get out and that's what I'm
going to do I have 32 moves left now so
I'm just going to go ahead and keep
doing this because this will fill up not
only the soda on this board but on the
two boards to come as well so that that
will make it a lot easier because if you
play this really fast in the first room
you probably end up getting stuck a lot
in the second room at least I did when I
first started playing it so that's how I
figured it user that's what figured out
to be the best um working on
so like Here I could just match this and
then it'll hit this it'll probably send
some other things but hopefully the bear
won't get over the string yet okay good
now just make another match underneath
no the bottle comb sometimes they pop
right let me come out so that's great
too but you also see there that no new
one comes out until it stops and you
bring anyone out so they won't just keep
coming you know they come out water
there's only one on the board at a time
it's not of 24 moves and while the bear
went up anyways if I hadn't if that
hadn't happened you got what i brought
brought it up at that point by making
that um coloring candy in the middle so
now we do want to move the bear goes
down on the left side first when it
comes back up to the soda so we really
just want to make these vertical matches
in front of it like I'm doing now you
can get stuck in this room sometimes
like where there's just no way to get
get through but you know if you come in
with like I said with about 25 moves you
generally can get it going when you
really stuck just make a fish on the
left side and send it and it'll eat the
candy that's in front oh well I got a
really good start here I could have
popped two more bottles and this would
have been filled up but you know I have
a lot of moves left I think here I can
just hit this color bomb against the
orange and that will get the one they
left up and now I just have to make like
to fish or so to get the one on the
right up we're not really going to see
it here but um whenever you don't get a
match in front of your bear like I did
there which is most of the time keep in
mind that the strike came in here like
the blue stripe below the bear there
there's one on each column so fill that
soda up first and then
let the bear move up and you'll see that
come together if there's matches over
there try to hold off until after it's
filled up a soda to make them in that
way you'll move the bear closer to the
top and as far as the basic strategy on
this board which you can get to see that
munches I always work in the bottom
three by three square there and just
keep making fish if I can I pop the
bottles I need to pop first and then
just keep making fish and then I'll help
move it across and if you can't if you
get stuck just move to the top and fish
are still really the best thing that you
can do at the top you might be able to
get something like a striped plus a fish
or a rat plus efficient metal just move
things along faster so once you pop the
bottoms on the bottom square look for
combos in the top square and just try to
conserve your moves and get over to
where those stripes are below your bear
so that you can use those to get them up
top alright I hope this helps please
subscribe to our channel so you'll get
notifications as soon as these come out
and like the video if you found it
helpful thanks